[Music]
well more than half a billion dollars in
federal money will be helping renters
and schools in the valley the state
legislature doling out money from the
latest federal coveted relief bill
the i-team's david charns live in our
newsroom to break down where exactly
this money is going david
yeah brian it's a lot of money and the
first and most important thing to tell
you is this is on top
of money where those budgets already
were so it's
extra money you could save for the state
all part of the relief bill
congress passed now a month and a half
ago let's start with rental assistance
in all 208 million dollars we'll be
going to rental assistance programs
the state division of housing estimating
this will help about 20
000 households 162 million of that money
spent right here in clark county
and the money going directly from the
state's account to landlords
now onto schools clark county school
district will be getting a larger chunk
of money out of this about 350 million
dollars
the money slated to help reopen schools
safely and outfit them with new
technology in this
covid era we're living in state senate
majority leader nicole cannizzaro
telling me today that some ways the
money could be spent is funding summer
learning
teacher training and of course
sanitation we're getting some federal
aid
into our schools that is going to help
us to address the concerns that have
really been illuminated as a result of
the pandemic
and that's what those dollars are going
to be used for so to put this into
perspective a bit the entire
general fund for the state budget over a
year is a little more than four billion
dollars we're talking
630 million dollars out of this out of
that chunk we just got from washington
so
it is a hefty chunk of change for sure
we do have a link to apply for that
rental assistance on our website right
now of course it is 8newsnow.com
live in the newsroom i'm david charns 8
news now